on a tenu denis raffarin qui est avec
lui denis c'est complètement fou parce
que denis il avait prévu ce que nous
sommes en train de vivre avec le
coronavirus c'est le seul voyons à avoir
vu juste dans votre prédiction pour 2011
c'est un truc de fou joli hein c'est
alors depuis deux mois le montant de vos
consultations est reversé à des causes
humanitaires donc bravo à vous donner ça
bravo bravo de le faire et ils demandent
aux voies non d'avoir un comportement
propre car ils sont beaucoup c lip
sollicité alors vous aviez prédit quoi
merci denis d'être avec nous donniez
merci de venir afin d'être là alors
bonjour à tout le monde bonjour aux
mêmes mois demandé comment savez-vous
bien des jardins comme étant à présent
on va être derrière adele a commenté
vous bien on va bien bien trop j'adore
alors donnez moi alors denis merci
d'être là et bravo pour ce que vous
faites denis de reverser à des causes
humanitaires
vos consultations brabo des données
comment allez-vous bien le conflit s à
confiner puisque là nous voyons qu'ils
puissent qui de 20 ans déjà mais il ya
ainsi l'humanitaire que je suis qui
travaille depuis 30 septembre militaires
dont des marocains des sans abri des
précaires à nouveau bravo données
parvenions de l'adie est donné vous
aviez witt vous aviez prédit cette cette
catastrophe
oui effectivement donc j'ai plein
d'idées sur les mondes il est utilisé de
pandémie virale
maintenant avant d'être voyons j'étais
gêné le visage des monuments de
l'utiliser ce terme-là écoliers bon
cyril clients soient tristes et
profondément malheureux lamé argent il
passait effectivement tous les paquets
entiers de nez juste en votre prédiction
comment vous avez vu cette pandémie
commence à se manifester vous vous avez
des visions comment ça se passe à
l'autre estime en moi que je fais des
publications cette année donc en fin
d'année effectivement donc certain
nombre de sites qui sont là bas il ya
deux positions
il y a je ne les fais tu as vu les
coronaires on a parlé mais j'ai
effectivement max dont diadji pour
l'aider à prouver suivante casser la
figure
celui-ci met la main sur formans désolé
oiseaux de mauvaise augure
voilà tout simplement nommé hier soir on
parle de bijoux le jeu de maintenance la
situation qu'il a des cellules cho merci
denis donner ses cours alors vous dites
qu'on parle du jour de maintenant dans
vos prévisions
vous avez dit il ya trois semaines vous
avez annoncé qu'on sortira voilà qu'il y
aura un premier des conflits nés entre
le 1er et le 15 mai c'est ce que vous
avez raison le départ à savoir si c'est
une grande pudeur plus fort mais voilà
il est pas mal et qui montrent bien sûr
le débat et savoir comment on va en
sortir
effectivement vous expliquez moi je la
mettais en europe et en europe
effectivement cela fin juin doit arriver
à se sortir effectivement dans cette
situation il y aura des cas encore que
l'on arrivera à gérer maintenant accord
la problématique c'est d'autres
continents effectivement le continent
africain
l'inde n'est pas bien sûr matip qui est
là bas merci alors est ce que je t'ai
repris les questions vous avez quelque
chose à voir avec jean pierre raffarin
notre ancien par ses notes au bénin
puisque jean pierre est un jeune ayant
percé c'est un ami à vous dans ce cas
précis c'est un cousin
c'est votre cousin laminé bâ web assez
beau baba très bien côté basse du médium
et la bravo pour ce que vous faites en
tout cas d'heuliez parce que ils
reversent à des causes humanitaires
bravo denis merci d'avoir été avec nous
et bravo pour votre prêt des prédictions
enfin bravo c'est vrai que l'on va pas
s'en réjouir parce que c'est une
catastrophe mais bon moi en tout cas
vous aviez vu juste merci